this is some of the best microscopic
footage of the year
it's from nikon's small world in motion
competition
where the best entries are selected for
their beauty and uniqueness
but there's much more to these images
than their eye-catching appearance
they're also helping to answer some of
the world's biggest questions
researchers captured this process of
melanoma cells morphing into two
compartments
footage obtained by placing the cancer
cell under extreme confinement
we can create environments in which we
mimic
the micro environment of the human body
and we're watching the cell adapt and
move in this micro environment
so we call one part the small round part
the cell body
and the long part the leader blair and
the leader blep
always leads the cell body to this other
location during cell motility
knowing how cells adapt and change in
this environment is a vital piece of
information
on how cancers form and move throughout
the body
to help understand cell motility
hopefully one day we can help
reduce the spread of cancer and he isn't
alone
scientists gloria slattum and stefan
datewiler were able to track the
development and movement of cancerous
cells in a zebrafish embryo
the small blue dot you can see moving
through the pink and purple dots in
other cells
these dots are thanks to a fluorescent
component that can be fused to any
protein
first extracted from jellyfish by the
late nobel prize winner roger chen
by filming the whole tissue we can
actually analyze what happens in the
whole animal
but then we can zoom in and look with
very precision that was happening in
particular cells and since zebrafish
share over 70
of their genetic building blocks with
humans this footage can help inform
research on how cancer cells interact in
humans
only if you know the context of a cell
we can truly understand
how it migrates through a body and how
it interacts and
which cells are important on its path
through a body the more information
scientists gather in this area
the more they'll be able to detect
cancer cells earlier in formation
and understand their movements after but
this type of microscopic imagery of
zebrafish
isn't limited to just cancer research it
can also help in understanding human
body development
the zebrafish is a really great model
because it's obviously transparent
as it develops and we can watch blood
vessels as they grow
that's exactly what you've been watching
here a zebrafish embryo developing
and forming blood vessels the speckles
shown in green
we're interested in the genes that are
involved in determining which vessels
are arteries and veins we're interested
in
how blood vessels know where to grow in
the developing embryo
understanding blood vessel development
allows researchers like daniel to track
and monitor how blood moves in the early
stages of body formation
a vital piece in the puzzle when
developing targeted therapies for cancer
treatments
you can also use similar techniques to
learn how that blood is pumped in the
first place
by looking at microscopic hearts a two
day old zebrafish heart to be precise
there's about one percent of babies that
are born with heart defects
for the us last year that represents 40
000
children and if we want to help these
kids we need to get
a lot more information about hearts
before they are born looking at how the
heart works in microscopic detail is a
major step
there's always been a sort of a question
of how this
heart pump what are the minimal elements
required
to to pump blood and heart and
that's what i'm trying to to uncover
anjali and her colleagues watch the
beating zebrafish hearts to pinpoint
specific functions and mechanisms
like how the heart beats without
backward blood flow which will help
uncover these mysteries and
importantly help prevent birth defects
and this technology is advancing so much
that scientists are now even able to
look at microscopic images of our brain
because this isn't a dazzling lightning
strike in the night sky
it's actually growing brain cells andy
moore a postdoctoral associate at the
howard hughes medical institute
looked at the growth of active neurons
in rat embryos
this footage shows a critical step in
brain development the period when the
neuron decides
which of the many neurites become the
axon the part that will be in charge of
sending an electric current
and until images such as andes this
information wasn't properly understood
it turns out a lot of these things that
we thought we understood really well
from textbooks
maybe didn't get things quite as right
as they could have now that we have
the live movies in front of us and all
these new technologies that we can use
to look at those questions
andy and his team can start to look at
how neurons transmit function
and develop in extreme detail as well as
looking at how these cells grow
and how proteins within the brain move
and push things around
which in turn allows them and other
researchers to see how severe
neurological diseases like als
form as well but other images in the
competition
went a little more old school and helped
shed light on important ecosystems
eric lynn captured this collection of
images of a freshwater snail embryo
in which you can see the heartbeat as it
develops
and richard kirby a plankton specialist
captured this horseshoe worm larva
these species might not be as well known
as other stars of aquatic life
but it's one of the biggest hidden
worlds of life on this planet then
changes at the bottom
will translate to changes at the top so
looking at the base of the marine food
chain gives you a way to understand
what's happening in the ecosystem and
changing the ecosystem in particular
but this year's winner of the small
world in motion competition wasn't alive
at all
the star of the show was a simple water
droplet
technically micro droplets that are 80
water and
20 ethanol the video was taken by
xiaoyen
and qazi robbie whose research focuses
on creating surfaces that repel water
which you can see happening in the video
something that could help manufacturers
create energy efficient technologies
like improving air conditioning units or
stopping pipes from freezing in the
winter time
or even preventing your glasses from
fogging up and it's this image that
encapsulates what microscopic images do
best bringing us all into the unseen
world of the small
and minuscule and offering a vision of
the future